hello everyone and welcome to another
wonderful game from the 2015 world cup
that was played in baku azerbaijan uh
it's a dingler and versus ernesto and
archiev
uh yes you guys probably remember him
from that game we had against magnus
cross in the double illegal movie was
quite a sensation if you haven't seen it
do check it out it will be the first
link in the description below uh
definitely a game for the ages that one
but this one
it features a sort of a calm opening but
then the game just explodes and the
dings knight is just you know uh
uh totally in the game uh for for like
the entire game but you will have to see
this one to to believe it so let's dive
straight into it the ding opens with c4
he goes for the english opening we have
e6 uh knights to c3 and now after the
argentor defense d5
we have d4 knight to f6 transposing into
the queen's gambit declined c captures
on the e5e captures and now bishop to g5
so
like i said nothing new here at c6 we
have e3 and bishop to e7 preparing to
castle bishop to d3 biting and not
knight b to d7 dingoes knight g to e2
and here while you could castle might be
a bit too soon for example castle's g4
could be a very very annoying so before
that black should move the knight so the
bishop has control over the g4 square
that's exactly what happens here
although first we have knight to h5 now
uh offering a trade of uh uh
dark square bishops bishop captures an
e7 queen captures and now queen to d2
ding says okay i might even be castling
queenside since you're going to castle
kingside we might have a castles of
opposite sides uh so knight to b6 again
not going for immediate castles because
now g4 would be even stronger so knight
to b6 and now f3 uh by ding uh now uh he
definitely might be interested in
gasoline queen side as f3 has been
played so he might have some ideas of g4
h4 but in the actual game uh g6 was
played and interestingly as of movie 11
we have a completely new game this
position has never been reached before
uh castles by being he castles king side
and castles by ernesto he also castles
uh king's side so it seems like it won't
be a
crazy game
but you would be very wrong ding plays
rook 8 to e1 and okay ding final finish
this development ernesto still needs to
develop the light square bishop and both
of the rooks so bishop to e6 and now
comes e4 so now ding has a very nice
control of the center and uh ernesto has
to figure out how to deal with this so
he starts by capturing
the captures back and now rook 8 to d8
developing the queen side rook and b3
now a very nice idea as not only do you
don't have to worry about the a2 pawn
hanging also you uh control the knight
here
without allowing it any squares in the
future so here bishop to g4 uh and here
comes queen to e3 uh with f6 uh weakens
the king a little bit but it gets more
control here over the fifth rank so a4
preparing a5 to chase away the knight
from here and now queen to b4 putting
pressure on that b3 pawn so being
defensive we have bishop to c2 and now
how do you play this well bishop
captures an e2 white it does control a
bit more space and the black king is uh
a bit more open so it makes sense to
trade off some of the attackers uh you
have to capture with the knight
otherwise we're going to lose the d4
pawn so being captures with the knight
and now knight to g7 shifting the knight
over to e6 uh and then we're gonna put
more pressure on this d4 pawn so here
rook to d1 biting and now queen back to
e7 and here
uh you can't really play something like
knight to g3 even though you would want
to because f5 is very very strong for
black the queen on e3 is undefended so
if f5 is played you're just not going to
be able to capture here so first we have
queen to c3 by ding and now uh you
pretty much have to play f5 that's the
whole point of this uh f5 and then the
game continues however uh here after uh
the the the the move in the game a6 this
gives ding too much time to to set up
any sort of an attack so here we have
knight to f4 now uh keeping an eye on
that e6 square but the biggest problem
is now that f5 doesn't work while the
knight is on f uh on f4 uh we're just
going to play a5 kick away the knight
knight to d7 and now play e captures on
f5 that's the that's the problem and now
uh you can see that the knight has
access to e6 and also one of the rooks
is coming to e6 so that's just game it
doesn't matter what you capture with
rocket e1 chases away the queen 96 is
coming i mean uh this diagonal will open
up this is game over so after knight to
f4 uh inner kill tries uh king to h8 but
now queen to h3 an incredibly strong
move now threatening this monster fork
that will uh well fork the entire
kingdom here so here we have queen to f7
guarding the g6 spawn and now comes rook
to d3 a beautiful rook lived by ding uh
also possible was something like a5 i
will show this because it's uh quite
nice after knight to d7 now b4 the move
you always know you have to play and
after
well you can see that black is very
limited when it comes to moves
especially with dink controlling that e6
square with the knight and with the
queen but after g5 we can even play
something like e5 and it's uh i mean
such an ugly position to play for black
but you would not survive this against
the ding so instead after queen to f7
rook to d3 was played i think has a
completely different idea on how to
continue this and now we have knight to
c8
knights the c8 with the idea of uh
re-maneuvering the knight but also you
know that it's going to get attacked
here after a5 is played
now ding plays b4 and g5 now attacking
the knight and uh hence the title of the
video what do you do here well ding
starts with bishop to b3 of course first
we challenge the queen queen to e8 now
putting pressure on the e for pawn and
now ding plays queen to h6 and what uh
what a beautiful dare to give uh a
strong grand master like ernesto in kiev
you can pretty much capture anything you
want you can capture the knight you can
capture the pawn here you know that rook
to h3 is coming uh but still if queen
captures any for you guard the h7 pawn
so what's the idea behind the queen
queen to h6 biting well it's a very very
deep positional idea and well we just
absolutely have to show what happens if
you capture the knight because that's
the most beautiful part of the game
that never actually took place so if g
captures on f4 ding's idea is rook to h3
now threaten checkmate and now you have
to defend somehow uh you will defend uh
with uh knight to h5 if you try uh if
you try queen captures uh on e4 here
then we're just gonna play rook captures
on f4 so there's nothing you can do here
you can play uh queen e3 check and of
course queenie one check just runs into
rook to f1 and then you have um the same
problems uh for example queen to e1
we're gonna block with rook to f1 and
now after queen to e4 now you can uh
well there's time for a lot of things
but even ideas like bishop to a2 to b1
will be enough to seal the game but okay
after rook to h3 your only option would
be knight to h5 you have to give back
the piece and now rook captures an h5
queen captures an e4 again we have to
guard the h7 square
and now h3 interestingly here you do not
have rook captures on f4 because now
right the e3 square is available to the
black queen the white rook is not on h3
so here this would actually be a draw
because now black would be able to use
all of the dark squares to deliver
checks to the white king queen c1
checking e2 queen b2 uh sorry b to check
and so on
so here white would have to play h3 and
now the position is just uh winning uh
completely for white because after a
move like let's say queen captures on d4
with check king to h1 now queen to d7
you gain control over this v7 uh or over
the h7 pawn bishop c2 and now how do you
defend we can play f5 but now comes rook
captures on f4
and after queen to g7 finally defending
against everything we're going to trade
here captures captures and now bishop
captures an f5 and it seems like black
survived because he's only down one pawn
but it doesn't matter there's no
surviving this position for example
you're gonna play uh because the h7 pawn
is hanging you're gonna play some like
h6 now rook g4 checked then this pawn
falls as well uh and so on bishop
captures and c8 captures captures
captures now let's say king e5 we're
gonna play a5 and uh well it's uh simply
too much now uh the the the black king
being in the middle of the board not all
that much for black to do and the white
having the two connected passports on
the queen side this will be completely
winning and it's only now that the ding
would actually be up upon not uh in the
previous moment where i mentioned it so
that's the idea behind the night
sacrifice that ding saw when he played
queen to h6 so the knight cannot be
captured uh ernesto figured this out and
he decided to go for queen captures an
e4 it's the only other move that makes
sense we are now uh covering the h7 pawn
and dingoes rook to h3 again uh
seemingly giving up the knight here but
now you can't capture if you capture now
then rook captures now you don't have
queen e3 check the valuable resource
that we discussed in the previous line
now you just uh have to play queen e1
check and after rook f1 queen to e4
we're gonna play rook h4 check and
slowly but surely we are going to take
away all the squares uh from the
uh queen occupying this diagonal let's
say queen d3 we're gonna play bishop c4
and finally after queen c2 bishop a2
again you can't capture because of
checkmate and next move bishop to b1 is
coming and that's it so after rook to h3
we have knight to e7 and
this knight's the e7 is crucial because
uh if you just play a silly move here
let's say you play a5
even though you are defending the h7
square there's the thread of queen
captures an h7 queen captures and the
knights the g6 a beautiful smothered
mate here as the bishop covers the g8
square so you have to be very careful so
ernesto figures this out plays knight to
e7 guards the g6 square now comes bishop
to c2 we are offering the bishop and
there is nothing black can do against
this beautiful idea uh
the the queen cannot move because if you
move away from the diagonal you're
getting checkmated so of course queen
captures bishop and now of course you
can see ding's idea but in case uh some
of you don't feel free to pause the
video here and find the only winning
move for ding while i give you a couple
of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on spotting that you
have to take away the control of this
diagonal from the black queen and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show of course the movie is knight to d3
and now there is no defending this or
rather there is but you have to give up
a lot of material so here you could
consider queen captures rook captures
but that you do not have enough
compensation for the queen two knights
is uh well sometimes it can be
compensation for the queen but not in a
position where the black king is wide
open like this so instead uh here we
have uh after this knight move we have
king to g8 now giving up the h7 pawn to
try and escape with the king but not
ding just captures queen captures an h7
king f7 now comes knight to e5 with
check again uh picking up the queen so
there was no saving the queen regardless
of what ernesto did king to e6 not just
queen captures on c2 f captures an e5
now rook to h6 would check king d7 uh
rook captures an f8 it makes sense to
trade off a little bit of material as
it's generally a good principle when
you're up in material you should trade
down rook captures on f8 and now d
captures an e5 now we have knight to e6
trying to hold on a little bit but not
rook f6 uh offering a trade of rooks so
rook to e8 and here queen to h7 was
played and after this move was uh played
on move 39 it was in this position that
ernesto inarchive resigned the game as
there is nothing more to be done here uh
any move you make it's a very simple win
actually queen f7 we go after the knight
and once you move the knight let's say
now we go rook d6 check and we check
mate to the black king now the rook
falls uh and that's pretty much it queen
captures here king b7 and now let's say
queen captures an e7 with czech king
here and rook to d8 will be checkmate
so after queen to
uh uh enough cave resigned and uh what a
spectacular victory by dingler and in
this uh
game of the 2015 affiliate world cup in
baku azerbaijan
uh so yeah that's the game i hope you
guys enjoyed it really a wild one and
really shows how uh
uh you know such a uh
such a slight imprecision here that
allowed this knight there for move in a
critical position you just have to play
it if you don't play it then you allow
all of this all of this uh because of
that one a6 move allowed the dink to
just fully mount the attack and
completely overrun black's position
uh so once again hope you guys enjoyed
it i would like to thank nagarjuna
pongotti
efri alas fine lemon alexandrino and
harish srinivasan for a contribution to
my channel thank you a lot to really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world so thank you all i will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your day and your week